this Saturday Rebecca Lowe will be on
the road with the full studio team in
Washington DC the Premier League
mornings live fan event this was a great
success last year live coverage of the
show and all of the matches begin at
7:00 a.m. Eastern on NBC SN roadtrip hi
Rebecca
I'm great are you going to visit any of
the the monuments there the White House
I was a bit of sightseeing but no we're
pretty much in Friday's full rehearsal
and I have to be up at some insane hour
like 2:45 a.m. yeah on Saturday morning
for get into makeup at 3:30
to be ready to go at 5:00 so and then as
soon as we're off there we have to get
trained back sounds like Connecticut
we've got the game the show on Sunday so
I'm basically in and out which is pretty
sad how long is makeup for you oh it's
about seven hours how long does it take
for Kyle Martino's hair your team is
Crystal Palace it's not any good this
year yes yes indeed I gave you a lie
store City a couple of years ago it was
so sad because I thought you don't want
no one's ever picked this team and the
odds are really long and then I go in
and and you're in the makeup room line
thing and I go or just came out and I go
I really like leister city this year
it's Leicester City I know and then I
said good luck because I got no charms
how did they go do something like once
it's like a frigging hundred year
lifetime if never happen again I
believed I believed I think I have a new
team this year
of course you do I'm over Hampton okay
lesson number one you can't just say
first of all you've got to get the
pronunciation right not Wolverhampton
it's all Hampton and secondly you call
them wool or you call them Wolverhampton
Wanderers you can't just go with a water
hammer it would be like me to thank Bay
yes okay so I'm going to once this year
my wall I mean okay I will put my
mortgage on the fact that they will
definitely not win the league but they
are a breath of fresh air they play
lovely football and you picked a nice
super manchester united's in trouble
right yeah they're in a mess that star
player and the manager at loggerheads I
don't know if you saw some footage that
came out from the training session this
week and the two of them are clearly
having words yeah yeah I just didn't
know if you knew that but you well I
don't know why I didn't think that of
course you know all the players and all
the team so yeah Paul Pogba Rosa marina
acting like a head 20 years ago there
would only be one winner
Josef Mourinho but these days player
power is so huge Paul Pogba was bought
for you know ninety million so he's much
more valuable to the club than josie
marino is at the end of the day and even
though in any other life if you speak to
your manager like he does or about the
employer like here at paul pogba does
you'd be out on your ear not in English
soccer
what about Liverpool versus a man
sitting Liverpool vs Man City you mean
for the title right yeah yep I gave you
those two or everybody else yeah I mean
Liverpool yeah I think it's gonna be a
two horse race I mean you don't you
never know with this Premier League in
it is really early but I actually think
they were poor might win it which will
be the first time since 1990 and they
have they just play oh it's so good to
what it's wonderful to watch and at the
back more importantly you can't win the
league you can't win the Premier League
unless you have a really good goalkeeper
and a really good backline because you
can win games with the you know only
scoring lots and many but you can't win
games of course if you let a ton in at
the back so they've got they sort out
their defense
sorted out their keeper plus they've got
an amazing front line so I'm gonna go
with Liverpool this season because I
think it's so difficult to repeat so
it's really like I guess it's like doing
the Super Bowl two years in a row it
must be really really difficult it's
even harder to win the Premier League
back-to-back for various reasons so I'm
gonna say that Man City this year will
miss out as difficult gonna win the
league what about the behind-the-scenes
that Amazon did with Man City where I
thought it was really well done and what
I love is you don't have to love soccer
to love behind-the-scenes I think you
have to be a sports fan because a
natural curiosity and all of our sports
fans we want to see the locker room
especially in England when we never get
to see anything in there at all we also
want to see those moments in the
training grounds at those moments
between in those meetings and it was
just I I binge-watched it I absolutely
loved it there are people who criticize
it I don't care it's entertainment
that's what it was supposed to be and it
was never before seen so but I want more
I want more stuff like that
Manchester City now it's different in
everybody's eyes and you know where's
the harm
for me the fans get to see the players
more as humans I get to learn more about
pep guardiola the manager and they get
to see how the club is run and what it's
you know we haven't got crewless like to
be in a Premier League dressing room to
be able to witness what it's like at
halftime in a game they're losing I mean
I've been in the game 21 years now
haven't that started off I've been in
the game 15 years in my career and I've
never been in a dressing room so that to
me was amazing best team for having pubs
closest to the stadium would be with you
which club probably probably Goodison
Park and it's quite next episode Western
brilliant they used to have one in East
London before they moved to the Olympic
Stadium there is a club in the division
below called Brentford they have a pub
on every corner of the pitch so
literally on the corner of every part
the stadium of the pub that's great and
they might get promoted next year so we
should have a pint dance program
but but Fulham soccer is shite isn't it
we were saying these words this is like
a flashback scene when you just came at
me with that W word and now you've done
it with the S word and I can't cope with
it so answer the question for them are
not brilliant they're not terrible but I
definitely wouldn't or wankers or what
shade of red is your face right now
[Laughter]
or is it bollocks okay have fun this
weekend Rebecca Lowe & Company
you can come out and touch Kyle
Martino's hair if you'd like in
Washington DC it's the Premier League
mornings live fan event and cover to the
show and all of the matches begin at
7:00 a.m. Eastern on NBCSN
I hope you're so how is Teddy oh he's
great dad you stood a hot crazy no once
again if he's good in soccer do we get
him or does England get him and mash out
the massive decision that you know my
husband and I talk about a lot already
I know presumptious but we do maybe wait
which is probably gonna be England let's
be honest so really good qualified for
woke up because you could be that's a
shot that's a shot I can have you
deported great to catch up with you and
have fun this weekend Thank You Rebecca
thank you that's Rebecca
she likes Crystal Palace NBC Sports
Premier League coast for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]